j'aimerais commencer par vous poser une
question qui est dans l'une de ces
banques
pas mal merci et qui n'a pas de banque
ok une personne c'est rare donc on peut
dire que la plus grande majorité d'entre
nous et bancarisés est en majorité dans
ces banques françaises avant d'aller
plus loin
j'aimerais vous raconter l'histoire de
deux soeurs qui réside en afrique du sud
elles sont nées en 2008 et répondent au
doux nom de medupi et kusile
année après année elles grandissent et à
l'âge de leur maturité
elles auront atteint leur pleine
puissance 9600 mégawatts l'équivalent de
11 réacteurs nucléaires
et oui figurez vous que méduses
irrécusable sont des centrales à charbon
qui se ressemblent c'est pour ça qu'on
dit qu'à son sort ce sont des méga
centrales à charbon qui produiront à
leur pleine puissance
l'équivalent de 60 millions de tonnes de
co2 par an pour vous donner une idée
c'est ce qu'aimer la ville de mexico
l'une des pluies des plus polluées et
des plus peuplées au monde sur une durée
de deux ans à terme elles deviendront
les troisième et quatrième centrale à
charbon les plus polluantes au monde
elles vont elles vont pardon elles vont
générer une augmentation des émissions
de co2 d'afrique du sud de 17%
qui d'entre vous aimeraient financer la
construction de ces centrales
cette fois personne mesdames et
messieurs je suis désolé j'arrive avec
une nouvelle pas très très bonne figurez
vous que ces centrales elles sont
financées avec votre argent et mon
argent aussi
et oui ce sont les banques françaises vu
tout à l'heure qui cofinance la
construction de ces centrales à hauteur
de 1,8 milliard d'euros
alors pourquoi nous clients épargnants
financeur de ces projets nous ne sommes
pas au courant alors déjà on n'a jamais
vu une banque
encore aujourd'hui qui faisait une
grande campagne de pub sur découvrir ce
superbe projet l'un des plus polluants
au monde vous le financer je pense pas
que ce soit la mode très rapidement mais
également parce que nous faisons pas la
question
un autre banquier notre curiosité
en tant qu épargnants s'arrête au taux
d'intérêt qu'on va recevoir sur tel ou
tel compte et au fait que notre argent
et bien non sécurité dans la banque
parce que épargné c'est jusqu'à
aujourd'hui quelque chose de très
personnel très intime et très
individuelle et lorsque l'on met bout à
bout ces démarches individuelles on se
rend compte que l'on finance
collectivement des projets dont on ne
veut pas en tant que société ont fait
émerger des projets nocif à notre propre
société
oui notre cochon notre petite épargne
elle a un impact elle a du pouvoir un
pouvoir qui peut être destructif comme
constructif pour notre économie pour
notre environnement pour notre santé
[ __ ] venir c'est une prise de conscience
que j'ai eus vers 25 ans lorsque j'ai
commencé à travailler dans le domaine de
la microfinance
c'est à ce moment là je me suis rendu
compte que de petits montants mis
bout-à-bout pouvait permettre de
financer des projets ambitieux positif
de territoire le micro crédit
c'est-à-dire le prêt d'un petit montant
pouvait transformer la vie d'un
agriculteur d'un entrepreneur d'une
coopérative
prenons l'exemple de jamal qui réside en
seine saint denis dans le 9-3 grâce au
microcrédit
il a pu acheter un utilitaire est un peu
de matériel pour financer son projet le
nettoyage écologique de voiture
aujourd'hui ils nettoient 150 à 200
voitures par mois
il a donc créé son propre emploi l'année
dernière il a même ouvert une nouvelle
antenne à bondy c'est un exemple parmi
des millions d'une finance de proximité
d'une finance qui a du sens d'une
finance positive une finance qui est au
service de l'homme et non de son
asservissement ni de celui de la planète
en france et dans bien d'autres pays
développés avec la concentration du
système bancaire ou nous a laissé
comprendre que la finance était
insaisissable compliqué un domaine
d'experts et de banquiers on nous a
donné l'impression que où va notre
épargne et à quoi elle sert ne nous
appartient pas
et pourtant pourtant nous épargnant
français nous sommes assis sur une mine
d'or 4600 milliards d'euros c'est dix
fois le budget de l'état en 2015 avec
juste 10% de cette somme on peut
financer la transition vers les énergies
renouvelables dans toute l'europe
alors on nous bassine depuis des
dizaines et des dizaines d'années en
nous disant qu'il faut changer de modèle
énergétique
mais qu'est que les financements ne sont
pas là et bien si demain
chaque français décidé de mettre 10% de
son épargne dans un projet d'énergie
renouvelable
on aurait déjà financé cette transition
imaginez-vous tout ce qu'on pourrait
faire avec ses 4600 milliards d'euros
alors il s'agit pas de volatilisé cet
argent il s'agit pas de le mettre dans
le jeu ou ou de le mettre dans des
projets non rentables non viables
économiquement très risqué il s'agit
juste de faire des choix conscient les
choix réflexe des choix réfléchi comme
par exemple le choix de changer de
banque ou de ne pas en avoir
allons découvrir la nef le crédit
coopératif la banque postale
ces banques qui financent économie
réelle et qui sont transparents sur les
projets financés
nous pouvons également faire le choix de
mettre une partie de notre épargne dans
une foncière qui dédié à l'achat de
terres qui seront cultivées en
agriculture biologique ou au logement
social sont des produits financiers peu
rémunérés mais sécurisé et qui voudra
garantissent que votre argent est
entièrement dédié à ce type de projet
nous pouvons également faire le choix
d'épargné en direct dans un projet qui a
du sens pour nous grâce au crowdfunding
cette fameuse finances participative qui
nous rend acteurs de l'économie en 2012
j'ai cofondé une structure qui associe
le concept de la microfinance est
l'outil du crowdfunding afin de donner
du pouvoir aller pagne de changer
d'énergie des 25 euros
une personne peut placer son épargne sur
8 10 ou 15 ans et produire avec ces
mêmes 25 euros de l'électricité verte et
produire en plus des intérêts
comparables un produit d'épargné
classique alors je ne suis pas là pour
encenser la finance participative et
d'autres l'ont fait avant moi en
particulier les médias car dès qu'il ya
de l'argent et encore plus sur internet
il faut prendre son temps il faut être
en éveil il faut se renseigner sur les
risques sur le sérieux des acteurs et se
faire conseiller si on se sent pas apte
de prendre une décision financière
néanmoins moi je trouve ça génial génial
qu'un autre échelle avec nos tout-petits
aux nôtres grand pouvoir d'épargnants on
puisse contribuer à changer de monde
dans le sens que l'on souhaite
gandhi disait soyons le changement que
nous voulons voir dans le monde
et si ça passait aussi par notre épargne
merci